hello internet friends my name is Donnie
O'Dwyer hi mr. peter brown hello mr.
Danny O'Dwyer how are you doing my
friends good welcome to this wonderful
world of high-definition deja vu that we
live in where it's 2015 and we're here
about to play resident evil HD
remastered is that the proper order
apparently okay even if it was
remastered HD it still doesn't really
make sense because it was never HD to
begin no this is a remastered version of
the gamecube remastering of the original
resident evil can keep remake i was
remade yeah you think the totally yeah
it was a Joe it was completely like they
came from mansion different characters
no zombies but they completely
overhauled that game and either they did
change around a few small things yeah
and we're about to play the version
which is coming out on a bunch of
different platforms next gen consoles
and PC we're playing it here on the xbox
one and we usually do some preparation
for these games but this is resident
evil some of us have actually bothered
to do it yet so we're just gonna jump
straight in here so nicely you can do
you want wider original we gotta do y it
all right we gotta show that off
alternate or original alternate because
I believe that allows you to get away
from the whole tank control scenario oh
really yeah Oh what if i like it like a
tang well then you want to go back and
choose original my friend Peter how do
you like your games do you like not to
strain you like driving a mountain like
going on a hike or like taking a walk uh
hike with me let's go on oh yeah it's
for Japan it's going a hike to a through
a nice wilderness forest ok so
differences between characters is
important ok um so oh oh you can switch
his skin oh wow so you can be like it's
a prezzie five chris redfield yeah ok so
basically uh chris is a little bit
stronger he gets like a like a jolt
thing yes sir we're not going to get to
that at this point just for people at
home he can't play the piano trying to
think he has a higher rate of like
headshots being successful oh really um
Jill's advantage that she has more item
slots yes and she's also got Barry
burdened by her side I believe chris has
Rebecca chamber
indeed but then gel is the master of
unlocking so that's right that's that's
also benefit who you want to go for I
always go Jill I'd like to go Chris
gonna go this weird new version of jail
or no I want to go Chris in a separate
always please okay which version Chris
let's go this guy's got ready 5 Chris do
it get all the great memories so good
fantastic Reza diva gains chris redfield
and was last time you watched the
original opening like from the first
PlayStation version like that Joseph and
Albert Wesker yeah well they cut in
people like they slide in from the side
and they do a close-up of their face
like making some wagers Russian yeah
it's been a while I don't think it's in
this one is it now the team is flying oh
so it's got this fish situated in I
think that they did it yeah they
completely redid everything yeah
computer cuz it was live action the
original one yeah it was yeah yeah
you're right this is all I remember this
on the Gamecube one right I think this
was not yeah this is yeah this is in the
game keep one yeah Tsar murder case and
he actually said that they had a lot of
these assets so kicking around so it
wasn't too hard for them you're kidding
yeah Wow when was the gamecube when's
that come at the original was like oh I
want to say two thousand maybe 2001-2002
yeah that sounds right that sounds right
we lost contact I kind of wanna watch
this oh well we have to watch yeah okay
look at this booty that was back on
Capcom had that deal with Nintendo
they're like resident evil will only be
on the Gamecube it will not go to any
other platforms are part of the Capcom
five yeah sort of but so it was like
this a beautiful Joe beautiful Joe
resident evil 4 piano three from
platinum games at the rest but like
Nintendo had that lock on rezzy for a
few games like this one Resident Evil 0
but then for for capcom was like yeah we
need more money we need to sort game
yeah it did eventually come out but it
wasn't for just on gamecube for the
longest time I know there was a pc port
eventually there's on ps2 I was there a
piece use oh yeah look at this this is
definitely not what the playstation one
version looked like
spoiler this guy's gonna die what's his
name again Joseph Joseph I all I'm
seeing is the ffv version about that
we're just cut you don't even see him
getting killed you just see him looking
shocked as like a first-person camera
draw goes towards him I think there's it
like that there's a different cut of the
opening in one of the releases like
every version of reasonable has
differences to even the Saturn one is
different a station like there's like
new zombies and like extra stuff so I
think they're you do see him die in one
of the cuts it's heated the director's
cut version they're like did I forget
what other ones came out but anyway did
she have mortgage well let's in her i
know she looks pretty non plus two like
oh look this dogs like mean james there
rana this is also the first time she's
seen any sort of like zombified anything
yes like it at this point she they have
no clue what's going on they probably
just think they're feral feral dogs i
always thought that was just one dog in
the in the original intro don't recall
hey you still have that see when you
open to the door yeah you guys rock and
the dog will that certainly come halfway
in the door and then it would cut Peter
that's the first thing we're going to do
in this game but you know oh my god bite
my arm Wesker does it BAM Chris this way
there was a comma there Wesker Chris
this is brenton yeah
why is Wesker even helping them like
he's got motives Oh Chris this way did
they keep the original voice acting no
no enter I received kept the original
animations where everyone just like does
the same suggestive most emotion with
their arm if what if this is chris's
blood left now bury her Jill Jill self
ooh we don't know where Barry is he's
upstairs boyers sorry sorry anyone who's
not playing present Nicholas Barry I
thought you were in the dining room what
are you doing here never mind that joke
no how did you lose him you literally
ran in the door together I'll go and
check it out on my own Dylan are
victorious that is costume from
revelations Chris I forget take care
well yeah why yeah whatever I'll just
check the noise on my own I know that's
the strangest thing about this like they
all split up let's canvass this entire
house after we just saw a bunch of
zombie dogs I am controlling this as if
from the I'm praying I'm pressing left
he's going left right he's going right
up he's going that way it's as though
you were not a tank it's amazing so so
this game wasn't made in 1986 let's pick
up this increment I'm assuming you know
I've never seen an ink ribbon in real
life do you have never seen an increment
in real life that runs out of ink after
ten characters there wasn't a typewriter
in this room before was there there was
Lister yeah and more to the point I'm
serious if you put an increment in a
typewriter in this game it should just
always allow you to save with that
typewriter without an increment because
you're yes because you're not going to
use the whole thing up and with
especially with Chris when you have such
a small inventory because it's a small
inventory keeping increments around is a
paint you can't do it so you have to
store it and then go back and get it
every time you want to say that's the
game isn't it isn't that the if I like
having not a half not having enough
inventory slots to be able to combine
that's who possess a part of it but
logically an increment will not run out
of ink after you type September 20
420 p.m. a Peter I wonder what's in this
room know what is anything in this room
what is it what wait is this the
original no no it's not it's it's up its
they show it there you know the same
sort of angle do they show the head
rolling away cuz that wasn't in right
but that was in the director's cut yes
he still looks freaky Oh no ha he is
better at close quarters than Jill as
well just like the original i'm going to
make are gonna fight from the rut best
at camera angle i think come on tlie rob
how do you feel about fix camera angles
shed I'm feeling pretty [ __ ] about it
right now what the hell yeah he's bi t
you need to talk down like original all
right one of the exclaims this game
added was the secondary weapons so how
did I mess that up I want to say Jill
you to chiller Chris one of them has
grenades and you stop the aid in his
amies mouth and they explode that's
pretty cool I don't remember the skyping
this hard well technically you should
just run away from oh really well you
know whatever caught him really hurt is
Jill gonna been here and shoot him for
me uh no oh yeah cuz I'm play sorry it
was when you're playing as jill when you
come out here yeah but uh the Wesker I
guess shoots him God is on with a screw
I forgot I have difficulty what though
so you can still talk up where that way
alright what else we go you're okay
y'all got my survival knife which I'm
not the doing a great job of the lighter
oh sorry oh god fine it's not necessary
that's not the item you were looking for
yeah the files has the map looking right
what a map and my health is not looking
too good we're already in the red so so
you might die but yeah feeling I'm
feeling like a bit of an idiot for
already getting bitten twice better you
than me forgot that you can't just kill
that dude I think there's a plant
somewhere in this room now don't waste
time looking for it because you're just
gonna die anyway nice to see they kept
the loading screens in here yeah it's
all about tension man we're on this game
does a great job using fix cameras for
the gamecube version and let it do so
many cool things with lighting there's
like one scene with like i'm sort of an
upward angle shot really long depth of
field like on the hallway and you can
just see the shadows coming from the
room ahead of you always a wall and then
as you walk your shadow gets cast going
towards those things yeah and it's such
an awesome moment yes I will 15 bullets
hmm let's check this door i wonder if i
can just walk out yeah i'm gonna call
the day 5 p.m. i'm done what what that's
the new isn't it I can't remember if Ian
didn't always come in with Chris can't
remember oh I know I feel like a right
[ __ ] died I know you take more than
three shots alright well are you ready
to open the doric looking pretty pretty
healthy there you go from caution to
danger only I could use those ink
ribbons as uh you know what I think
maybe this one in here in the statue
room is doing the ticket hopes are you
too sir oh yeah the hallways is this is
the small horse game alright let's do a
puzzle I wonder what I'm supposed to do
now there's typically a zombie around
the corner after you go in here and here
it depends on who you're playing as I
think does the text come up like before
when you look at things
so to push that thing you need to move
it a little bit more to the left so you
can get to it it's like yes or science
side yeah there you go yeah thought
imagine playing this game for the first
time in twenty fifty year old [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] is no dude in there I think
yeah but I don't know if he'll active
well does it [ __ ] it to do it your
Anjali I'm just wondering if it's
changing if I'm okay so there isn't i'm
back there to pressing up yeah okay gets
it keeps it it keeps the downward press
to mumbai yeah okay or awkwards okay
zombie in that room over there there's
one in that hallway but i'm pretty sure
either way there is an item back there
now I'd arif I cuz I'm shortest in the
original one at least they always am the
dog just they played that animation
nothing ever came in yeah I don't recall
it coming in either yes please take them
up take it why doesn't this map have
locations of all of the delicious green
herbs what I want to know all right I'm
too scared to check that what you want
take that room yeah I want to check that
ring you got to see this sweet loading
screen again we're not going into the
hallway anyway what's really good I
don't want to go into that hallway
because we know I'm gonna have another
dog to kill god I feel like such an
idiot forgetting wait a second how did
this go back oh its original position
creepy just go for it just do it walk
with confidence
by that I mean wrong
I don't think there's a zombie
various art supplies what's on the
corner great yeah I didn't have one of
those so the dagger you have is that the
thing you have to inspect to get
something off of it let's have a look
let's have a closer look defensive item
where is the Duggar oh no the dagger is
the defensive item oh yeah it's not a
key item so yeah so then its Jill then
that has the grenade that she can shove
in a zombies mouth as her defensive item
was that is that just a game keep owning
one all right yeah that was Adam that
was at it for that oh [ __ ] I forgot
about this you all right I totally
forgot about this yeah you get up you
[ __ ] idiot hi hi wait let me have
control so I can shoot this jerk love me
up oh you know I'm your head under ID on
that I'm that Oh defensive item is he
dead you should be dead very hot
supplies are those are supplies while
you're looking good Jesus the brains
really paint well I'm this canvas thank
God for that you definitely need some
herbs yep alright so upstairs is the
crows upstairs you can also get to the
garden which you could you couldn't get
to from that door or maybe is it down
here they added the door to the garden
in this version as well we're in the
first game you had to take a different
route to get there can't use any of this
stuff gap right well that's creepy
wonder what's on the other side chris is
such an idiot
no that's different yeah if you go if we
don't wanna go down that hallway how
could we go up into the left and this
was so the doorway is right here to the
back here yeah that's new right exactly
that was in the the remake rice not in
the original it's not gonna be hunters
out here already is he yeah and so yeah
it's anything to chris has to fight the
plant or Jill does not cuz she's a
master of unlocking yes oh I already
feel like I shouldn't be one different
the cell your find out you're fine out
here there are herbs I could've sworn
there herbs here we got some nice angle
yeah right like that's so the thing you
can only get me compose scenes through
okay so if you go into the piecing it
all together in your mind I can hear us
I know you get that from the dining room
there's like a thing above the fireplace
you like take the arrow and then take it
apart and use that dagger the arrowhead
to put in there all I want is our on
Arab even the shotgun shells to me
around God though it's locked don't care
give me a shiny thing I was on the other
side and yet it shines oh alright gonna
go back in you go in the hallway I'm
gonna go on the huh I'm gonna go on the
end not the one with the doggie I'm
gonna go with the one but the dog
doesn't that didn't come until a little
bit later it's right there I think it's
free to marble I thought a marble
hallway I thought was the first time you
do it well it's the first time you do it
but is that the hallway for sure I think
so i'm gonna go this way instead all
right do it what's that one in there on
the left I remember that mmm bathroom I
remember the one on the other side is
where the crows are Wow got that plus
you're really good at like resident evil
Foley yeah it's that there is a zombie
appear if i recall at least it wasn't
the original game on one side though he
can dodge him first that dumb stash push
the stupid starch oh no Chris you
[ __ ] owe push him away
oh great great grand it's gonna save
dead I am dead you didn't save did you
I'm dead inside for already losing it
resident evil it's okay they can fix it
in post we can we can we can jump back
in with Jill perhaps let's rewind a bit
yeah that's where they take to being a
bit resident or not you want to do it
with different yeah let's make a deal
sandwich well tell you that janna dude
this original display or yeah we're not
original controls yep alright let's see
how difficult it is to control in yeah
so I wonder by doing that have they
removed the like difficulty of the
difference between Jill and Chris by
adding in that little difficulty slider
doubt it no yeah I hope not that's that
seems a bit out of the spirit of
resident evil and we're gonna for the
sake of brevity and skip this intro
pretty sure it pretty much the same for
bro cactus I kinda want to open the door
again to all of you to see no no don't
die this time daddy there are only three
stars members left now who Mary and
myself wait where's Chris don't know
where Chris is oh my god
what is this place mmm they kept the
same like Mary tone yeah hey whisker
where's Chris Jill no hahahaha go back
out there they've redone the voice
acting but it's really not that much
better most Wesker doesn't really know
how to speak at a proper like cadence
Chris this way hello I'm going with her
crusin with my gigantic gun and mine I
love my red jumpsuit because big that
gun is that's preposterous stay sharp
thank you why aren't you coming with why
you like just hanging out in the hall is
like I like this architecture of the
other you just come back to me you guys
investigate all right
alright was also shocked by the length
of that loading screen
all right oh it's so weird yeah playing
with tank controls glad to have the
option now yeah be honest so for those
who don't know I'm pressing forwards up
to go forward at all times many rotate
using left and right yeah exactly yeah
based on her perspective so I'm hitting
right writing he's turning right look at
this maybe this is chris's blood right
why is he looking mallet Jill see if you
can find any other clues I'll because
I'm gonna spend some time with his blood
oh it's not Croesus they've changed the
I'm just gonna look at it and touch it
gonna rub it on my gun he's not he
wasn't even looking she won't walk away
yeah just give me a leave me alone with
this blood how's the guy have to do to
get some privacy around here yeah all
right I've seen it first you can't have
it well I've learned my lesson we all
know what to do here by the way she is
walking slowly by default i think i have
to run modifier and add to it yeah we
know nasty nasty nasty all right get the
[ __ ] out of here
get out of here extron and that Barry do
the rest with his massive hand cannon
yeah seriously very what is it
let me take care of it something three
shots before those head explodes i love
that that resetting a bizarre yeah let
me really shoot him this time i
preferred the original because then you
had a really satisfying head explosion
yep when he finished it off mr. Wesker
yeah that's reported to the worst
manager ever he just delegates
everything hey where's cares which
occurred on here yo sunglasses we found
a zombie huh huh huh like I still alive
terrifying about Wesker still here it's
weird like the widescreen non widescreen
version it's just like typical black
bars on the side yeah like what's not I
can't see any reason to play with this
at all well it's only for cinematics
that they do that oh yeah you know to
make it more cinematic let's see if you
can swap a backyard let's go wide on
that and then controls alternate please
and defense items auto that's
interesting really huh so I don't
remember that being an option I guess I
was for the knife when Chris Stubbs that
dude in the the temple take me 180
degree turn as well Oh is there one of
us yeah i just hit down and swear was
one on there was in the gamecube remake
as well huh he uses the right stick i
don't know if you push it in or if you
push it down yeah push it down you're
right you oh no actually either if you
touch in any direction or click again
it's a straight I like it pretty huh
which kind of us redundant now that you
can just like in tank controls rag right
you're like a missing today that's for
you hey ball right where's where I want
to go home I go upstairs
very don't open that door what's the
stairs the loading screen before yes yes
you click on and go up yeah do that
that's slow at a finished searching the
whole first all yeah forgot all right
looking for that's all you do is you go
up the stairs and then go down oh and
you're done I feel like so much of this
game just won't read with the 2015
audience is paying for the first time
what's going on around here I can't
figure it out why is your gun so big
Chris I'm just you know its compensation
okay you can search for him separately
I'll investigate the dining room again
ok then I'll try the door on the other
side no I won't elevators going back to
the dining room this massive mansion is
like I gotta check out that room with
the blood again maybe I didn't look at
the yeah oh here we go you'd make better
use of it why why would she make better
use of it Barry what term would you what
listen let's meet up in this hall how
would you know if something happened ah
as in plots of something already
happened really how are these people
qualified authorities on defense and law
enforcement you didn't even call it a
massive unlocking what a dick maybe the
whole was upstairs actually remember
it's been a while yeah well I think you
might be right about the first floor
thing let's uh let's see if that to see
I love this like this would be so much
easier if you could just see how they
both can use either the dagger or the
grenade I guess huh weird and then they
give it to you there again had to use it
so we see on the other side you're gonna
go in the foreground was there something
where yeah if you like right Dale auto
yeah so there is now yeah you would say
that I think I always tells the same
stories an emblem of a sword maybe this
is some sort of sword keep i love that
angle got this game was so clever ok
look look at this thing puh-puh-puh push
it hey I love this cuz berries
presumably down there so I was gonna
drop this [ __ ] statue on his head
where's this guy he's over there stuff
good he doesn't we know by he doesn't
have abstract thought he doesn't realize
that he can walk around he's there
where's the steps down wasn't there a
door or maybe that was the door XD just
can't get into it yeah mmm you can't get
into that one on the left no it said
this is the sword key one oh sorry yeah
I guess it was I don't know I forget one
in which way like I forget how actually
restricted this game was quite early on
where's this guy's right here is me
using all those precious bullets I
should just run away yeah you know like
now use a defense that yeah take that
you are playing on the Hard difficulty
tier so they're gonna take more bullets
oh did I pick the hardest yeah not the
easiest yeah alright sorry whoops ok
let's go for one one more little venture
rancher what else what else would you
want to see if this was the first few
minutes Oh last few minutes about it oh
dear will it go to that hallway go
downstairs isn't good can't get enough
what is it I don't want even as I you
rush yeah it's the we can't get it to
the bridge editor comma s word key I
love the birds so much i would go yeah
go to that small door next to the map
room awesome do it let's see if a dog
jumps through the window there's a bunch
of things in that hallway that you can
push to there's like two different
pieces of furniture that have items
hidden
them and at the end of that is the room
with the itchy itchy I'll regulator show
you a helmet please don't Peter see it
right now 20 what about little hidden
route now should we go back into Barry
and maybe the hallway beside him I don't
like the one we were in with the oh yeah
I know where you can continue through
there let's try that I bet it is you
still here where's your daddy gone AWOL
I should see what I want to see what the
same thing looks like as well actually
using ribbon yes no saving not loading
eight save slots take that previous
generation consoles great yep hey was it
successful I'm not sure because you
won't let me move on watch you get this
sweet thing God yeah well it's going on
the black market after i get out of this
stupid mention okay so it look above
look at that shield so i think if you
take that and examine it there's a thing
or no you have to replace a different
thing with that so yeah I take it that's
all coming back what zombies gone as
well not only their blood again ha Barry
took the blood all right brides gone to
the bathroom with the blood too oh [ __ ]
look at that guy I don't think is gonna
come at you yet good because I'm not
gonna come at him look at dude here oh
[ __ ] he's gonna attack me as Nick no no
you can look at him I don't trust you
one bit no I'm being legit oh it's
Kenneth what you got I need a VCR to
watch this again 2015
she's like when you drive in it haha ooh
what's in this door I'm guessing a
poorly lit hallway look just be oh look
at this yeah right like uh yeah it's so
infuriating this game is like just what
the stairs 00 eventually there are
hunters here like later in the game
right a little bit of dishes here yeah
that's the hallway that was talking
about so if you walk forward you can see
that there is the shadow from the
birdcage I don't to be lewd but cap
common really want to sort out their
physics because there is a lot of
unnecessary movement happening with this
character model see well you know what
this way if you go back see the
chandeliers like casting that shadow
yeah your shadows there i mean it's just
such just your head i like the little
mirror on the left there as well this is
the room with the oh this should have
been where we went i believe dude behind
you will get up as well and also there's
a typewriter in this room behind us in
there wasn't there oh no I got one
there's you sure yeah I got you in just
a case using the resident evil engine I
love this cuz you gotta gotta get close
enough to then when you push down yeah
he's done also pro tip Resident Evil
fans don't waste bullets checking bodies
I want to combine two herbs it's
important to me for super herb super
green herb you get that powder right
yeah mixed herbs and then the red one I
think was what made it more powerful The
Riddler makes its Trump minutes like a
blue lose like the antitoxin one yeah I
think you could do red and blue together
as well what's behind door number three
that's a crimson it he is going to upset
you I'm pretty sure that's a crimson
head there is a guy over there i think
is there yeah i want to say yes oh
that's that's real out Jesus know that
guy comes back to life when you come
back that's all works ah wait on a big
hard mode it takes so many shah's it's
the bathroom oh so this is where you
need the shield and you replace it with
a gold shield oh so yeah you're fine
you're fine it's only when you take the
shield out that the thing starts to move
my goddesses I didn't really sister is
this unlocked another early he a damn it
examine the shield yes i will take the
mansion key oh I did exactly what we
didn't want it out Jesus yeah I examine
the shield let's see I can't move I
can't move I'm just want to explain
right now I cannot move you you will be
ok ok check it what check the shield for
the [ __ ] key [ __ ] Vicki exists under
the keys in a book now examine examine
no line with ink ribbon
turn it there's something is there a
zoom in on it on the front of it now
guess not ha you gonna put that key back
Oh like taking a dump I was terrifying
yeah I definitely up my puzzles mixed up
in the head oh man all right let's
finish this up I gotta kill at least one
zombie in hard mode that's my that's my
goal let's do it I do you have any
chance of items left I have a knife have
you reloaded your weapon oh thanks for
winding me about Resident Evil oh it
doesn't matter i don't have an extra
plate so it looks like a gosh survival
knife which is not actually defensive
item that's a regular one yeah so just
guess I have a gun and I had a lot of
green herb snoop would be proud just
dude wake up guy wakes up its I hope
whatever all right o our hands going
through the wall that's great 2 out of
10 ha yes for our review of this game
and many more of course make sure to go
to gamespot.com headshot oh yeah hello
he's probably gonna get that is he
unless you see a pool of blood I'm gonna
raid us let's go for it man you had
nothing to lose except your life Oh
everything is for voting in this game ok
so you examine that to s yeah nice fur
outside yeah so many mirrors I remember
that Jesus Christ get off me you piece
of dirt wait can I go in that room gives
that get the clip get the clip what
where is a clip on the ground we're back
down in this door no but where's the
bomb he will like this i unlock this
mansion key thank you oh I didn't see
the clip I'm sorry I panicked I'm gonna
blame the fantastic hour up here great
grand
right last thing we're gonna do is open
the door with Jill and see if the dog
comes out oh no we're here again yeah
it's important to me to find out you're
like gel is a better relationship with
dogs oh yeah so for those who are
interested a resident evil remastered HD
resident evil HD remaster it's got to be
remastered aged the remix is as tomorrow
tuesday the whatever date of the month
in January Tuesday's my birthday was the
fifth that's the only dated and Johnny
ray I care about I'm happy birthday
thank you yeah it's on ps3 xbox 360 ps4
xbox one pc and pc as well here we go
moma truth nope she's a stupid she's a
stupid Chris oh Jesus oh wow wow the
force of that dog it's good thing I have
one polish man Oh your ratings uh uh we
are dead good alright that's that thanks
hanging out folks after our review and
further coverage of resident evil and
other video games and estate agent
gamespot com p right thank you very much
i study yeah my president evil
you